justin timberlake is speaking out in
support of his ex britney spears
how proud of her are you oh completely
couldn't be more could be more proud
the 40-year-old crimea river singer took
to twitter to speak out after the pop
star whom he dated from 1998 to 2002
gave a shocking testimony during her
latest conservatorship hearing
writing in part quote after what we saw
today
we should all be supporting britney at
this time he went on to say that
regardless of their past
what's happening to her now is quote
just not right
as for britney's claim that she has an
iud in to prevent pregnancy
and is not allowed to remove it in hopes
of having a child
justin wrote quote no woman should ever
be restricted for making decisions about
her own body
no one should ever be held against their
will or ever have to ask permission to
access everything they've worked
so hard for the man of the woods singer
wrapped up his message
saying that he and his wife jessica biel
send their love and support to brit
adding quote we hope the courts and her
family make this right
and let her live however she wants to
live
during wednesday's hearing the lucky
singer called out her father
jamie spears and alleged that the
conservatorship holds her back from
living her life
this is very important that she's
decided to speak out now and i think
she's doing it because
basically she's come to a head and she
needs to figure out
what she's going to do about this
conservatorship and she thinks
this is the best way to get her point
across i think it's a very big deal that
she's speaking out and
she has told the court she wants her
voice heard
britney expressed that she would like
nothing more than to quote end the
conservatorship without being evaluated
and would like to regain control of her
life she also shared a slew of shocking
allegations against her father
and her team she was very passionate
that it should end
and that she had been wronged and abused
e.t spoke with the director of the
unauthorized documentary the new york
times presents framing britney spears
samantha stark she was sitting front row
for brittany's testimony
she also said her management she felt
forced by her management to perform and
go on tours and that she
would be punished if she didn't she
mentioned
visits with her kids and her boyfriend
could be taken away she also said
that things like that she wanted to get
married and
have a baby but that she had an iud in
and
she said that they she felt like they
wouldn't take her to the doctor to get
it taken out
following her testimony the attorney for
her father said in a statement to the
judge quote
he is sorry to see his daughter
suffering and in so much pain
mr spears loves his daughter and misses
her very much
when i first started i didn't know what
i was doing but every day you learn more
and you gain more wisdom from that
meanwhile back in february stark's
documentary for the new york times was
released
and explored everything from the pop
star's rise to fame
to her negative portrayal in the media
along with her ongoing conservatorship
battle with her dad
we started doing this researching for it
i guess early last year
and the the purpose of it was to look
back at the media coverage of
brittany especially around like 2007
2008
uh through a 2020 at that time lens
it also touched on britney's former
relationship with justin
some of these old interview moments that
come to light um like justin timberlake
and the fallout of their breakup what do
you think people will react to to some
of the ways that brittany was treated
and even some of the things justin
timberlake said at the time
the most shocking thing about that for
me is that there wasn't
an outcry about it like no one it
it wasn't in our popular culture to
think that there was
something wrong with the things that we
now consider like very misogynistic
it just seemed like very much in the
culture to be able to
shame women for their sexuality
following the documentary's release
the former nsync singer released a
public apology to brittany and janet
jackson
after receiving backlash for how he
handled both his highly publicized split
from brittany in the early 2000s
and the infamous wardrobe malfunction
with janet during their 2004 super bowl
halftime performance
in his statement the grammy winner wrote
in part quote
i specifically want to apologize to
britney spears and janet jackson both
individually because i care for and
respect these women
and know i failed
[Music]
at the time a source told et that
britney was aware of the documentary
adding that she has no interest in
discussing her past
relationship with justin quote she
wouldn't want her fans to speak
negatively about him because she has the
utmost respect for both
justin and his wife jessica biel she
laughed about how people are talking
about it now
it happened so long ago
you